اون لاين طبق الدستور
ولحتى نكون ملتقى مين وقاعدين بالمجلس
لحتى ننتخب رئيس عتمه البلاد وعتمه مجلس
النواب تعطيل مشترك فكان الدعوه النائبين
ملحم خلف ونجاه صليبه للبقاء داخل المجلس
والمبيت فيه للضغط من اجل عقد جلسات
متتاليه لانتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه
لانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه
هو من ضمن الدستور ومن ضمن القوانين انه
ما بدي 74 والماده 75
والوطنيه بتحمل المسؤوليته وبتحمل نتيجه
قرارات
الجلسه المقبله لانتخاب رئيس الا ان
الرئيس البرلمان نبيه بري وبدل ان يدعو
الى جلسه الانتخاب دعى الى اجتماعا لج
نيابه المشتركه
كل شيء بيطلع بايدنا نعمله اعتصام مفتوح
واليوم رد علينا انه حتى جمع في انتخابات
جلسه رئيس جمهوريه فيعني في استهتار
بمعانات اللبنانيين من قبل فريق الممانعه
بالبلد بشكل يوصف خصوصا بحزب الله وحركه
امل والتيار الوطني الحر يللي اليوم لا عم
بيرشحوا حدا ولا عم يقبلوا ينتخبوا حدا
وعم بيعطلوا بنفس الوقت
جلسات انتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه وبيرجع
وتحدينا التيار الوطني الحربي بيرجعوا
بيتباكو على ما يسمونه
المداخل المؤديه للمجلس اغلقها الجيش
اللبناني تحسبا لدخول متظاهرين الى محيطه
الجمهوريه وبندعي كل الشعب اللبناني بانه
ينزل على الشارع
صلح
المنطقه
النواب وحتى الاعلام المعتمد في البرلمان
منع من تصويرهم خطوه اعتبرها البعض عمليه
تعتيم مقصوده لمحاولات انقاذ البلاد هذا
تحرك سيستمر بحسب ما يؤكد النواب لكن ما
لا يمكن تاكيده ان ياتي بالحل المنشود رغم
ان التدهور وصل الى اعلى مستوياته مع
تسجيل رقم قياسي جديد لانهيار العملاء
ناهد يوسف العربيه بيروت